comment ne pas succomber devant
l'absurde
l'absurde lorsqu'on est une femme née en
france en 1970
l'absurde de naître dans une société qui
ravage les ressources de sa terre
nourricière le sait et continue à foncer
tête baissée vers sa propre perte
l'absurde d'études supérieures
j'utilise encore et toujours les mêmes
techniques et les mêmes outils que dans
un siècle révolu
ces techniques qui nous ont poussés dans
l'impasse nous sommes aujourd'hui
l'absurde encore d'une carrière
internationale pour finalement réaliser
que la valeur du travail ne repose que
sur le profit et la rentabilité
l'absurde enfin d'un fléau qui n'est pas
un virus qui ne s'attrape pas mais que
nous développons avec nos propres
cellules le cancer et un tas d'autres
absurde auquel vous avez sûrement été
confrontés vous aussi la liste est
longue quand l'absurde n'est pas
conscientiser un jour ils vous frappent
en plein vol
il m'a fallu 38 ans pour commencer ce
travail de conscientisation afin de ne
pas succomber devant l'absurde
à 38 ans j'étais directrice
internationale du planning stratégique
dans un groupe anglo saxons et l'absurde
de mon rôle rendre plus riches des gens
déjà très riche me questionne depuis
quelques temps
je décide de démissionner afin de mettre
mes compétences au service de causes
réelles celles qui contribue un peu à
réduire l'absurde peut-être la crise de
la quarantaine mon peu des parts est
organisée au siège à londres dans une
tour haute sécurité de la city costumes
et tailleurs sombres mes collègues et
collaborateurs me font de très jolis
speech et je découvre que j'ai un surnom
pas n'importe lequel il est masculin et
décrit l'un des plus grands guerriers de
tous les temps
attila
un choc qui va orienter la suite de mon
parcours
je commence à travailler bénévolement
pour différentes ong afin de tenter à
mon niveau de réduire un peu l'injustice
sur cette terre mes compétences sont
utiles pour lever des fonds qu'il
s'agisse d'un orphelinat en haïti ou
pour acheter des terres volées par les
conquistadors aux peuples racines ces
derniers héritiers des sociétés
précolombiennes
c'est en 2010 que je les rencontre enfin
ces indigènes précolombien porteur d'une
autre façon d'être au monde il se nomme
l'écho be on estime qu'ils sont encore à
peu près 20 milles retirer dans la
sierra nevada de santa marta en colombie
le coeur du monde comme ils disent cette
montagne au pied de la mer des caraïbes
qui culmine à 6000 mètres d'altitude
je découvre que ce peuple premier
racines certains diront qu primitif vit
et travaille en harmonie avec la nature
depuis plus de 4000 ans
ils savent comment
éduquer former bâtir cultiver sans
aucune technique technologies ou
connaissance de notre monde moderne et
ça fonctionne depuis des millénaires
alors avec beaucoup de candeur je suis
subjugué par leur façon de travailler en
harmonie
travailler ensemble en harmonie
les hommes entre est il finalement
capable
existerait-il encore ailleurs dans un
coin reculé de notre planète des sages
que nous avons voulu exterminer avant de
les oublier
intrigué voire interloqué je décide de
poursuivre mon engagement à leurs côtés
afin de tenter de comprendre comment des
hommes et des femmes peuvent vivre et
travailler au quotidien sans guerre et
sans violence parce que la guerre et la
violence serait elle finalement
évitables
l'homme moderne s'est il déjà posé cette
question primordiale
ma vie ici continuer en parallèle on me
propose une nouvelle expérience
professionnelle alors je me dis pourquoi
pas une façon peut-être de tester ce que
l'écho qui vont me montrer
comme je ne crois pas à l'altruisme sauf
à s'appeler et matthieu ricard ou mère
teresa mais que je crois ou win win aux
icônes et chic comme disent les
coquilles je te donne tu me donnes je
les aide à récupérer leurs terres
ancestrales et à sauvegarder la
biodiversité
l'écho qui m'aide à comprendre comment
je pourrais manager en harmonie c'est la
genèse de cet extra ordinaire
cheminement qui deviendra un processus
de management humain vivant durable
la seule qui dans ce que me l'écho
qu'ils me donneront pendant les six
années de recherches qui vont suivre
sera tout est écrit dans la nature il te
suffit de comprendre les lois du vivant
il n'y aura pas de cours de manuels de
méthodes de leur part ni même de beaux
mots vous avez ces mots que nous on aime
tant est qu'ils ne sont que bruit il y
aura l'exemple vivant de ces hommes et
de ces femmes qui au quotidien dans
chaque geste chaque acte chaque mot
respecte ses lois de la nature
celle que nous nous avons oublié sans
doute par vanité de toute puissance à
penser dans notre modernité que nous
pouvions tout maîtriser tout contrôler
pourtant je vais découvrir que si nous
avons l'humilité de les suivre ces
principes offre à chaque être de vivre
de grandir et de s'épanouir en harmonie
alors je démarre mon observation du
vivant parce que finalement je vis
depuis des décennies et je ne sais même
pas comment je fonctionne et les
entreprises le savent tél parce que pour
piloter cette ressource dites humaines
encore faut-il savoir comment elle
fonctionne vous le savez comme moi le
pouvoir sans connaissance mène à
l'autoritarisme
grâce
à mon étude des colis je vais assister
pour la première fois aux principes qui
s'appelle l'altérité
les coyotes une décision à prendre
arrêtez ou poursuivre la vente de café à
des torréfacteurs colombien en échange
de graines et de semis leur commerce se
fait en truck c'est leur monnaie des
changes
le soir venu les hommes se rassemblent
et vont aller discuter entre eux pendant
toute la nuit le lendemain au petit
matin vers 4 heures les femmes se
réveillent et vont à leur tour se réunir
pour échanger une bonne partie de la
journée le jour suivant un homme et une
femme que je n'avais pas
particulièrement remarquée annonce que
la vente de café sera arrêtée parce
qu'elle génèrent des conflits
parmi ceux qui avaient vendu du café
certains ont reçu de l'argent et avec
cet argent ils ont acheté des biens et
les autres en ont voulu naturellement
la convoitise et le vol se sont
installés au sein de la communauté
il ne punissent pas le fautif il cherche
à modifier la source qui génère le
problème puis prenne une décision qui ne
sera ni bonne ni mauvaise mais qui doit
être juste en fonction du contexte donné
chez eux comme je vais la prendre pour
qu'une décision soit juste il faut
qu'elle s'appuie sur deux jambes la
vraie rencontre de l'altérité la vie du
masculin et la vie du féminin sans quoi
la décision ne sera ni juste ni pérenne
dans le temps et donc non féconde une
fonte d'ailleurs faire le test du
flamant rose pour me faire ressentir à
quel point ce besoin d'équilibré vital
si vous vous si nous voulons tenir dans
la durée
ce premier principe je vais le prendre
et je vais le mettre en place dans
l'entreprise où je travaille à cette
époque là
je suis chief officer de la stratégie de
l'innovation dans un groupe de treize
mille personnes à dubaï je propose au
comité de direction où je suis la seule
femme dans cette société arabe de tenter
un premier pas concevable pour cette
culture
harmoniser le salaire des femmes sur
celui des hommes je motive cette
proposition sur la nécessité de renforts
c'est l'attrait de notre société pour
les jeunes générations de demain il ne
s'agit pas d'un mythe ou ni même d'un
quota politique je viens de réaliser à
quel point il s'agit d'un principe bio
logique pour pérenniser les
organisations dans le temps
les membres du comité de direction ne
vois pas où se trouve le sujet parce que
d'après eux l'écart est insignifiant
donc négligeable
avant de clôturer le sujet je suggère
que le drh calcul cet écart le calcul et
nous annonce
4 millions de dollars
je crois que c'est la somme annoncée qui
est le plus d'impact dont personne
n'avait pris la peine jusque-là de poser
un chiffre sur un sujet devenu normalité
la décision d'équilibrer les salaires
sera prise et cette société sera bien
avant la plupart des entreprises
françaises l'un des premiers groupes
international a annoncé avec fierté l'
équilibre de ses salaires
alors va se dessiner entre le
moyen-orient ou j'expérimente et la
colombie où j'observe une spirale
évolutive de neuf principes
afin de travailler
en paix et en harmonie
en observant la façon de vivre déco guy
jeu conceptualise neuf principes
altérité
sistemi vision dialogue cadre valeur
créativité tant mémoire un processus qui
s'il est mis en place dans le bon ordre
permet enfin de travailler en paix en
mai en ayant pour objectif de pérenniser
les organisations tout en permettant aux
humains de s'y épanouir
alors tout ça et bien je le joli mais
comment ça fonctionne concrètement
prenons un autre de ses principes la
vision avec un exemple simple la
construction d'un pont
avec les matières naturelles à leur
disposition sans clou ni marteau mais
avec des lianes et du bois
l'écho qui vont construire un pont en
deux jours
en silence
chef pour les guider et ce pont durera
50 ans
avant chaque projet
l'écho qui prennent du temps pour se
rassembler et parler entre eux
ils vont évoquer l'intention le bien
fondé du projet la vision la
contribution de chacun le moment
opportun
les matériels nécessaires
alors et seulement alors la date de la
construction du pont sera décidé
chacun sait ce qu'il a à faire quand le
faire comment le faire à quel moment
mais surtout à quoi ça sert le chef n'a
plus besoin de parler puisque la vision
est claire et a été partagée à chacun
des acteurs
grâce à ce projet chaque collaborateur
aura sera fier de sa contribution au
projet commun et les rouler les
fonctions seront renforcées
s'cusez moi
chaque collaborateur sera fier de sa
contribution au projet commun cela n'a
rien à voir avec devenir une entreprise
a mission écrire une vision d'entreprise
qui me concerne généralement que les
cadres dirigeants ni même rédigé un
manifesto je parle ici de donner du sang
chaque matin à chaque collaborateur au
sein de sa propre équipe
comme la construction du pont la
biologie pour faire l'analogie confirme
que même notre corps respecte ce
principe il s'appelle l'homéostasie
une recherche permanente d'équilibré
entre chacun de nos organes afin
d'atteindre la vision commune qu'ils ont
nous maintenir en vie si l'équilibré
perturbé par ce que nous mangeons nous
courons notre corps s'est instantanément
rétablir l'équilibré sans que nous ayons
besoin de nous en préoccuper
l'homéostasie et naturel lorsque la
vision et l'intention sont clairs et
partagés à chacun des organes y compris
le plus petit parce que si l'un de ses
organes ne sait plus quoi faire se sont
perdus
ou réagi trop tard la maladie pour la
mort sont assurés
alors je finirai par un dernier de ces
principes parce qu'il me tient à coeur
et qu'il est vital pour les
organisations mais aussi pour notre
avenir la créativité
force est de constater qu'aujourd'hui en
entreprise on utilise toujours des
techniques et des outils pour rendre les
équipes créatives
pour les utiliser on enferme les humains
dans des salles en béton une journée
voire deux si le sujet important et on
de 8h à 19h on pense faire des
séminaires de créativité honnêtement ne
reste plus qu'à prier pour que la
sérendipité cette intuition fulgurante
nous vienne en aide depuis des décennies
on perpétue
c'est technique vous avez sans doute eu
la chance ou la joie d'expérimenter
ce type de créativité a fait naître ce
que nous appelons le progrès notamment
en matière de maîtrise d'évolution et de
technicité
à favoriser le confort la vitesse et
l'allongement de la durée de vie
pouvons-nous pour autant dire que nous
vivons mieux plus heureux plus serein
il est quand même intéressant de
constater que le taux de burnout et de
dépression ne cesse de croître
l'écho qui nous appelle les petits
frères car pour eux nous ne sommes que
des enfants qui jouent aux apprentis
sorciers
conscience observations et intentions
conditionne les manifestations
auxquelles nous donnons forme nous
distille alors à quoi avons nous donner
forme qu avons nous créé
plus d'entousiasme plus de joie plus de
bien-être plus d'équilibré psychologique
ou physique
des têtes mieux fait dans des corps plus
sain
l'observation des maux de nos sociétés
modernes nous oblige à constater que le
volumes d'anti-dépresseurs augmente que
l' équilibre de la masse corporelle
explose
que la pauvreté ne cesse de croître et
que d'après les dernières études plus de
60% des jeunes se disent très inquiets
face à l'avenir
l'enjeu de la créativité n'est-il pas de
retrouver une capacité à réinventer un
art de vivre et de travailler ensemble
l'un des plus grands génies de tous les
temps léonard de vinci disait ça chez
vous éloigner car lorsque vous
reviendrez à votre travail votre
jugement sera plus précis
l'écho guimond dit d'observer la nature
les animaux les plantes on appelle cela
le biomimétisme mais ils ont ajouté que
comme dans la nature le temps et
l'espace était déterminant et de ne pas
oublier que le vivant devait être mature
pour pouvoir féconder ce que nous
appelons ici l'intelligence collective
lorsque un plus un égale 3 en réunissant
ces éléments préalable nous pouvons non
pas être mais devenir créatif une nuance
qui semble anodine mais qui pourrait
réellement tout changer
alors pendant une année j'ai organisé
une fois par mois malgré des agenda
surbooké une journée dédiée à chacun de
ces principes avec mon équipe
ce temps comme pour le bon vin nous a
permis de grandir de mûrir et de
développer notre intelligence collective
puis nous sommes partis une semaine loin
de dubaï pour avoir de l'espace et
sortir du cadre sommes partis à la
montagne dans les alpes et là nous avons
enfin vécu un séminaire de créativité
qui a notamment changé le nom de mon
équipe nous étions partis strates et la
division stratégie et innovation à notre
retour nous étions tellement prolifique
cas lantern notre appellation est devenu
lé goldmines
j'avais offert à mon équipe les
principes du vivant pour grandir et
développer une intelligence collective
j'avais ajouté du temps et de l'espace
pour les laisser réinventer leur manière
de vivre et de travailler ensemble
pour notre entreprise venait de naître
entre autres la nurserie le premier
laboratoire d'innovation interne dans
une entreprise de rites elle est un
nouveau concept de parfum oriental
comprendre que la nature n'est pas un
réservoir de ressources inépuisables à
exploiter mais une source d'idées et
d'innovations s'est révélé époustouflant
à titre personnel interpersonnelles et
professionnels
et finalement vous l'aurez bien compris
il ne s'agit pas de devenir kogi ni même
d'idéaliser cette société racines
ce qui est vital pour nous c'est de
comprendre comment ils ont pu réinventer
leur capacité à vivre et à travailler
ensemble malgré les pillages les
attaques et les génocides subi et répété
alors après ces années grand écart entre
la colombie et le moyen-orient la
spirale évolutive les neuf principes du
vivant est devenue concrète
parce que je l'avais moi-même
expérimentées elles étaient
opérationnels pour tous par tous
alors quand j'ai à nouveau démissionner
à 48 ans
une chaude et moi de soirée à dubaï j'ai
reçu de nombreux témoignages de
gratitude de la part de mes
collaborateurs et de mes collègues dont
un bracelet que je porte ce soir sur
lequel est écrit in spirit tional enjoy
attila et est devenu un enjeu
aspirationnel et s'ils ne pas succomber
devant l'absurde c'était simplement
faire le choix du vivant merci
[Applaudissements]